Все спочатку. Як діти вчаться ходити, так я починаю вчитися все по-новому.
Я не знаю, як жити. Реально я не знаю.
Вийти на прогулянку містом.
Здавалося б, буденна справа.
Але для Андрія Захтея - справжня розкіш і водночас випробування.
Я мерзну сильно. Руки повідбивані,
в мене вони постійно холодні й затікають постійно,
тому я з цим маю справді серйозну проблему.
І що вже тільки не пробував…
Так, крапельниці прокапав, на якийсь час стало трошки легше.
Майже сім років Андрій Захтей просидів у російській в'язниці.
Його затримали у серпні 2016-го в тимчасово окупованому Криму.
Тоді на півострів зайшла українська диверсійна група,
у складі якої був і нинішній очільник української розвідки Кирило Буданов.
З боями їм вдалося покинути Крим.
Коли Буданов уже публічно сказав про цю спецоперацію,
то тепер я можу сказати, що я став учасником якоїсь спецоперації.
Я не люблю те слово, бо я не є спец.
То такі гучні слова. Поміг людям - чим зміг.
У секретній операції, деталі якої не розкривали роками,
Андрій Захтей відповідав за логістику.
Скількох російських силовиків тоді вдалося поранити і вбити - досі достеменно невідомо.
Жорстко били, дуже все жорстко було.
Говорю так, як є.
Ніхто там по голові не гладив.
Уявіть, перестріляли ФСБшників, а мене одного затримали.
Можете собі уявити, що вони зі мною робили.
Там купа трупів, і нікого не взяли. Група пішла.
Взяли якогось Андрюху, відповідав за якісь конкретні дії.
А Андрюха навіть поняття не має що й про що,
тому що Андрій не ставить дурних запитань по телефону.
Із моменту затримання, каже Андрій Захтей,
почався найжахливіший період його життя,
оговтатися після якого не може й досі.
Хоча в Україну колишній політв'язень повернувся майже пів року тому.
Перші дні - підвал ФСБ.
Потім на тиждень я заїхав у Сімферопольське СІЗО.
Я сидів у таких відділеннях, як карцер. Окремо.
Тримали, бо не знали, куди садити.
Потім вертоліт, летимо, море, Ростов.
Потім машина і "Лефортово", ФСБшна тюрьма.
Потім там, потім звідти назад в Крим, в тюрму місцеву.
Під час ув'язнення Андрій Захтей зазнавав найрізноманітніших тортур.
Можуть прийти молоді курсанти ФСБшні,
відкрити Ютуб, подивитися якісь тортури,
а потім їх на тобі спробувати. Ну а чому ні?
І сидять теж те знімають собі на пам’ять.
Утім, найжахливішим, каже, було катування струмом.
Заходиш в кімнату: стіл, ліхтар, стоїть машинка, що б'є током.
Ніхто не ховає. Ти заходиш і розумієш, що перед тобою.
Підчепили і давай. До генеталій, до дупи. До чого завгодно.
Ліпше б били. Якщо били и палкою чи кулаками, то одне.
А коли тебе гасять током кілька днів поспіль, повірте мені, згадаєш все.
Та попри всі знущання Андрію Захтею вдалося витримати ув’язнення й не зійти з розуму.
Треба мати розуміння, по-перше, куди ти потрапив.
Якщо ти думаєш, що в якийсь фільм попав, то є твоя перша помилка.
По-друге, ти мусиш показати себе.
Тюрма - це зовсім інше. Це як країна в країні.
Там свої правила, свої закони, свій цар.
Потрапляючи туди, в першу чергу, треба розуміти,
як себе вести будеш, ким жити там будеш.
Людина - така істота. Ти все одно будеш виживати.
Повір, будеш виживати. Нікуди ти не дінешся.
Каже, за ґратами кожен рятується по-різному:
хтось починає писати, хтось поринає у читання.
Проте основне, що за що тримаються в неволі, - надія.
Ти живеш надією. Куди б ти не попав, як би тобі тяжко не було,
але все одно настає такий період, коли ти вже просто звикаєш:
що це камера, що оце отак, що воно кожен день отак, інакше не буде.
Я дитину свою не бачив.
Їй було пів року, коли мене посадили.
Я жив тим моментом, що вона мене чекає, що вона мене не бачила,
а тільки на фотографіях і в телевізорі.
Але запорука виживання у російській тюрмі -
не створювати проблем для її адміністрації, пояснює Андрій Захтей.
Особливо це стосується політв’язнів,
адже про них часто пишуть українські та іноземні видання.
А це зайвий клопіт для керівництва буцегарні.
Якщо там буде написано, наприклад, що Андрій сидить в колонії номер один, наш політв’язень й так далі.
То є одне.
Але коли будуть писати, що мене там б’ють, п’яте-десяте, їсти не дають,
таблеток не дають, то ти створюєш проблему.
І все, зовсім інакше йде розмова, коли ти дав якесь слово,
то на якісь певні речі вони закривають очі.
Бо закривають очі, якщо ти говориш: "Про колонію я писати не буду. А ви що мені?"
І починаєш торги, тому що тобі там треба жити.
У лютому Андрія Захтея звільнили з колонії,
проте російська влада не дозволила йому виїхати в Україну
і помістила до Центру тимчасового утримання іноземних громадян у Ростовській області.
А згодом забрали всі документи, аби колишній політв'язень
не зміг перетнути кордон і повернутися в Україну.
У мене навіть забрали довідку про звільнення, щоб мене Латвія не пустила.
Ну все зробили для того, щоб не пустили, але не додумалися, що в мене в сумці подвійне дно.
А там всі копії всіх моїх документів.
І все, я сумку розриваю на кордоні, дістаю копії.
Прикордонник: "Йди, тебе там чекають". Ті раз і прозріли, що пройшов.
Утім, навіть після звільнення боротьба за життя триває.
Перебування за ґратами сильно підірвало здоров'я.
Що я там заробив? Гепатит С хронічний… Зробився хронічним.
Хронічний простатит… Від бетону зробився хронічним.
Гастрити є. Руки повідбивані, сухожилля.
В наручниках били, товкли. Руки німіють, спина болить, купа проблем.
Крім того, через катування струмом Андрій Захтей втратив вісімнадцять зубів.
Те ще було давно-давно - у 2016 році.
В ФСБшній тюрмі було. У мене заболів зуб.
Там була жінка одна. Коли вона робила мені знімок,
то вона мені одразу сказала: "Тортури? Струм? Усі зуби вилетять".
Вони всі в мікротріщинах.
Адже коли чіпляли "плюс-мінус" за мочки вуха, то струм через що проходить?
От зуби і почали сипатися.
Каже, лише на протезування зубів пішло 190 тисяч гривень.
А на боротьбу з іншими хворобами знадобляться мільйони.
Приміром, взятися за лікування гепатиту готові в Німеччині,
але вартість курсу сягає сорока тисяч євро, розповідає колишній політв'язень.
Тож через брак коштів вирішення проблем зі здоров'ям відкладає на потім.
Мені брат трохи допоміг грошима, то я проколовся.
Прочистив судини, трохи серце і для печінки трохи крапельниці поробив.
Так, вибачте, дружина зайшла в аптеку, купила на 5 днів крапельниць
й таблетки для сну - бо я без них взагалі не сплю, я сплю по кілька годин через нерви -
так вона 4,5 тисячі лишила крапельниці.
А де уколи? Де всі інше?
Взятися за якесь лікування й думати, чи мені сьогодні вистачило,
а завтра не вистачить, то ліпше не починати.
Хіба гірше зробиш.
Тож нині Андрій Захтей просить всіх небайдужих допомогти зі збором коштів на лікування.
Адже найбільше мріє повернутися до нормального життя.
Треба розвиватися далі, щось думати. Ну, а що?
У мене дитина в другому класі. Мені треба годувати її, мені треба жити далі.